hi there Steve Kaufman here again and
tonight I'm going to talk about what I
call my language learning cradle credo
credo CRE do in other words what are my
beliefs when it comes to language
learning gonna try to summarize the
kinds of things that I talk about quite
often here at my channel I get
criticized from time to time from two
quarters when it comes to language
learning either is from the more
academic language learners those who are
very happy studying grammar and who
sometimes have a linguistics background
and at the other end of the spectrum
I am criticized by those who claim that
I'm too academic too interested in
reading books and that really people
should just get out there and talk and
it's very important to it's not like a
native so you've got either I'm
considered too academic and I don't
fully understand the importance of
speaking and speaking like a native or
at the other extreme I don't have the
credentials to or I tend to you know
gloss over some of the important
linguistics underpinnings of language
learning including such things as the
international phonetic alphabet and
knowing terms such as morphemes and
whatever so my credo first of all I
think language learning is a very
personal activity you do it for yourself
you do it so that you can communicate
with other people so that you can access
other languages and other cultures and
therefore I think we do it however we
want it's our personal thing and
therefore I've always felt that a
teacher is standing over me takes away
from that sense of my personal thing
teachers asking me to tell them what the
meaning was of this passage of teachers
as is now you know often the case with
ESL teachers teaching critical thinking
in other words teaching me how to
interpret the language how to think and
so it's up to me language is personal so
that's the number one thing you do it
however you like to do it it's you it's
your acts and it's your use of the
language it's you it's a part of you
it's personal the second thing is that
you know I often talk about
three keys which is attitude time and
the ability to notice and I still
believe that that's the overwhelming
thing attitude is perhaps the largest
element are you confident do you like
the language do you want to learn do you
think you can learn those attitudinal
things are huge time it takes a lot of
time with a few exceptions most people
need to spend months and months and
possibly years to achieve a high level
of fluency in the language and the third
thing is this ability to notice that
I've mentioned before and and the good
language learners notice things in the
language they hear the pronunciation
they hear the intonation they notice
phrases they pick up these phrases and
as they notice things the brain
eventually starts to incorporate these
into the brains sort of system for
managing that language and pretty soon
you're able to use them no I am very
much in put focused some people like
output I don't believe you can start it
out but some people actually say you
begin by speaking I don't see how you
can begin by speaking because you first
of all have to get the language in you
even if you do a lot of speaking as
scratch-free points out mostly you'll be
listening at the beginning because you
have so few words you can't say very
much so input however you do it whether
you acquire your input through internet
interacting with people or whether you
do it through listening or watching
television or reading or any combination
of those input is key so when I talked
about the time spent with the language
that's time spent in any way that you're
interacting with the language that you
are acquiring the language you need to
spend a lot of time but my preferred way
of studying is through input because
it's so easy to organize I can pick up a
book and read wherever I am on the bus
on the train I can listen in my car it's
so much easier to organize that there
are some people my good friend Keith
Swain who describes himself as social
linguist and he only likes to learn
languages where he has an offer enough
opportunity to talk to people in that
language but I can't do that because I
don't spend my day learning the line
I don't spend my day in a language
learning environment I spend my day
working I have my wife I have my friends
I got my old-timers hockey twice a week
a business to run I got other things to
do I can't drop all of that just to
spend time with people who speak Czech
because I happen to be learning Czech I
can't tell my wife that I'm going out
twice a week to have dinner with Czech
speaking people so it's just not
practical for me to organize my social
life around learning whatever language
I'm learning but it is practical for me
to devote an hour or so a day half an
hour here 20 minutes they're looking at
my iPhone while I'm sitting in a
doctor's waiting office or whatever it
might be I can arrange for that input
that way so I'm very strongly Pro int
because it's more practical in my sense
and it's equally effective you don't
need to speak now when we get to output
I will of course agree that to speak
well you have to speak a lot to write
well you have to write a lot however
when you choose to start that will
depend on your opportunities but the
more input you have the more tools you
will have to have the more words you'll
have the more familiarity you will have
so when you need to start speaking
you'll speak and and somehow you'll
stumble and you'll speak but the more
input you have had the better you will
speak but to really get good at speaking
of course you have to speak a lot now on
the subject of grammar you know of
course we look at grammar but to me
there's not that much in grammar like I
have some I have bought various books on
grammar here's a book on Italian grammar
look how thick it is you know here's a
book on German grammar essential German
grammar is this thick I mean it doesn't
take long to go through it here's one on
Swedish grammar haven't yet read it but
I thought I should get it just in case
there's not that much there you can't
possibly learn and just by looking at it
but you can leave through it from time
to time
and it helps but it's not a big part of
learning the biggest part of learning in
my opinion is
is acquiring the words again getting
back to input now another thing where
I've not necessarily been challenged but
I recently said that it's it's futile to
think you're gonna speak like a native
and people said oh well you know if you
really try you can and you should try
and soak and so on if I think of the
people that I most admire you know
non-native speakers of language it's
people who use the language well who
have a rich vocabulary who have solid
phrasing who expressed themselves you
know clearly and accurately with just
the appropriate word usage and so forth
and so on those are the people whose
language use I admire not those that
consider hi I'm gonna gonna like you
know like yeah and so like when I was
saying was like you know and somebody
who's picked up a very colloquial form
of English has very few words and can't
express himself very well I'm not
I don't respect people who speak that
way who are native speakers and I
certainly don't respect non-native
speakers who who speak that way so so
the idea that you scored there you have
about you know a couple of thousand
words and you're you're you're fluid
yeah you're able to operate the guts
what you want to do but if I say what do
I want to do who are the people that I
admire who use my language it's people
who have a lot of vocabulary and who
speak well and the way you acquire
vocabulary is through a lot of reading
it's truly in our own language people
who are well-read use the language well
express themselves well and it's the
same for non-native speakers of a
language such as English so you know
that's my credo nah it's my credo it's
my belief I don't have any peer-reviewed
you know studies according to some
rigorous scientific methodology that
proves any of this and I don't believe
in those studies because I have spent a
fair amount of time reading through the
different studies on how you acquire
vocabulary and how you do this down the
other and they're all more or less
contradictory and so it still boils down
to what I said at the very beginning
language learning is a personal thing
you do what you like to do it's you
that's gonna be
speaking the language the language will
represent you you do it the way you like
to do it and if you like a certain
activity you'll do more of it and the
more you do of it the better you will
learn so we don't need in my opinion the
rigorous you know peer-reviewed whatever
studies we basically need learners to be
committed to learning to enjoy the
process to spend the time to develop the
ability to notice if they do those
things they will improve and I would say
that the likelihood that that many
learners will end up being mistaken for
a native is so small but it's not worth
worrying about that's not to say that
you shouldn't try to pronounce as close
as possible to the native pronunciation
but it shouldn't be the number one goal
the number one goal is to use the
language well to express yourself
clearly and in a way that the native
speaker finds pleasant and as a native
speaker I know that I find it Pleasant
when I speak to a non-native speaker who
uses the language well regardless of how
native like their accent is so there in
a nutshell a bit of a ramble on my
language learning credo
thank you for listening and I look
forward to your comments hi there there
was one thing that you know I listen
through my video as I sometimes do and
one thing I wanted to add or correct an
impression I don't necessarily just
admire or respect people who speak
English well or speak other language as
well so when I said I admire those
people who use the language well I'm
talking about those people whose
language skills I admire I have had many
dealings both professionally and
socially with people who do not speak
English well both native speakers and
non-native speakers many of these people
I very much admire and respect and enjoy
their company and we have a great time
together and and I also know people who
are excellent at using the language and
whom I don't admire as people so there's
a difference between people that I
admire and respect as people and people
whose use of language I admire and
respect so in my video when I said I
admire people who use
the language well whether native
speakers are non-native speakers I was
in I was referring specifically to my
sense of admiration for their language
skills not necessarily for them as
persons nor was I do I believe that
someone who doesn't have good language
skills is somehow less admirable or
worthy of respect then someone who has
good manners skills because there are
many many qualities that we that go to
making a person and language skills
there are just one amongst many others
so I just wanted to add that point